this video was sponsored by brilliant
org to learn more about the natural
world through solving problems go to
brilliant org forward slash Simon Clark
the Marvel Cinematic Universe or MCU is
an unprecedented achievement of
franchise filmmaking across 22 films and
11 TV shows the MCU ties together
hundreds of characters and plot lines
weaving a hugely complex tapestry that
is somehow still understandable and
ultimately emotionally satisfying in the
recently released final part endgame
this video will contain no spoilers
incidentally so no need to stress one of
the most striking aspects of the MCU is
the setting of many of its stories
ranging on earth from America to a
condor to America to Germany to America
to Nepal to America but beyond earth the
MCU showcases some fantastical world's
some similar to earth and others which
are incredibly alien who are you dr.
Hannah wake furred is a planetary
scientist at the Space Telescope Science
Institute and an expert on planets
orbiting other stars exoplanets go like
this one in this video using her PhD in
EXO planetary science and my PhD in
atmospheric physics we're going to
review every planet shown in the MCU
to determine which ones could really
exist first of all some ground rules we
will only be using information from
films in the MCU
not the comics yep no thanks
we'll be determining if the planet could
exist as they are depicted in the films
that means both physically and also
biologically if that planet is shown to
be habitable we can do this by comparing
the MC use planets with planets and
exoplanets that we've discovered as well
as the laws of planetary and atmospheric
science so with these rules in place and
28 planets moons and astronomical
objects to consider are you ready
the MCU kicked off in 2008 with Ironman
the only planet to feature was our very
own earth so yeah I could definitely
exist
Ironman was followed by the mediocre
Hulk which again only featured earth as
did Iron Man 2 but things got a lot more
interesting in 2011's Thor features
earth represented by America alongside
two other planets
Asgard home of the gods and Jotunheim
home of the frost giants Asgard is shown
to be a flat disc rather than a spheroid
ie like a sphere like all planets we've
observed so far most planets are
slightly oblate meaning that they have
an equatorial circumference larger than
their polar circumference earth for
example has an equatorial circumference
of 40,000 and 75 kilometers and a polar
circumference of 40,000 and 8 kilometers
meaning that the planet isn't a perfect
sphere but more reverse squashed sphere
like a tangerine the flattest furrowed
we've discovered so far is the star
called a kinnor in the constellation of
error darkness which is 64% of its
equatorial diameter at the poles but to
achieve this flatness it has to be
spinning at 225 kilometers per second so
a planet could conceivably be flat like
as God is shown to be if it were very
low density and spinning very very fast
which is definitely not the case for
Asgard so as it is shown not even
getting into the seemingly infinite
supply of water on the planet Asgard
definitely could not exist without a
strong foundation of magic
now those foundations are gone sorry as
well as Asgard Thor introduces Jotunheim
Jotunheim seems to be a frozen planet
made of ice falling apart at the time of
the movie due to a lack of the magic
Hannah do you want to talk about the
role of magic in planetary physics now
okay taking magic house at the equation
then Jotunheim is pretty similar to
planetary bodies we've observed for
example during the New Horizons mission
Pluto was observed to have mountain
ranges made of ice and other solar
system bodies such as Miranda Titan and
Ganymede exhibit cryovolcanism
cryovolcanism is the equivalent of
volcanic activity on earth but in places
that are so cold that liquid water
behaves like lava does on earth volcanic
features like lava flows volcanoes and
eruptions have near exact counterparts
on icy worlds with liquid water instead
of liquid rock this would potentially
explain several features we see on yatin
height such as these hexagonal columns
which appears similar to columnar
jointed volcanic rocks on earth such as
the Giant's Causeway in Northern Ireland
for this theory to work the planet would
need to be extremely cold but as
Guardians seem to be basically
indestructible from an environmental
point of view so that doesn't seem to be
an issue
yatin home is also shown to have a thick
water filled atmosphere which would
cause extensive hydrological weathering
and so could explain the features such
as giant caverns which we see in the
film as long as the Oppenheim was
located far from its star still
maintaining a low surface temperature
with a thick atmosphere then it could
definitely exist surprise that's it for
phase one apart from a brief appearance
in The Avengers of sanctuary palaces
asteroid looking home which we see more
often guardians of the galaxy this is an
interesting one because we see features
like sanctuary all over the place in our
solar system every gas giant in our
solar system has rings of rocky or icy
material around them most famously
Saturn has a large flat ring system we
also have multiple large asteroid belts
in our solar system
so geologically sanctuary is absolutely
possible
however the density of material and the
surface gravity shown in the films is
much too high for a small body such as
an asteroid and because
this the atmosphere on sanctuary would
definitely be too tenuous to breathe if
it exists at all that said the MCU
showcases artificial gravity technology
on spaceships and it's not exactly clear
what the requirements are for Loki and
the others physiology so with some
biological hand-waving and treating it
more like a ship than a planet sanctuary
might possibly exist phase two of the
MCU kicked off in 2013 with Iron Man 3
which again only featured earth however
things got a lot more interesting in
Thor the dark world said no one ever
this film features seven planets of
which we've already met earth Asgard and
Jotunheim leaving Sparta prime vanaheim
Muspelheim and Niflheim smart all time
is the home of the Dark Elves a blasted
planet with a thick rolling atmosphere
with tinges of orange it also has a
rather unique looking star every time
it's shown its eclipsed an eclipse
occurs when one astronomical object
appears directly in front of another on
earth the Sun appears eclipsed 20
between Earth and Sun by some cosmic
fluke the Sun and Moon actually appear
to be the same size in the sky on earth
while the Sun is 400 times larger than
the moon it's also 400 times further
away that means that the moon neatly
blocks out the Sun leaving only a corona
visible around the edges spot all time
seems to experience an eclipse
permanently that means that it needs not
one but two cosmic flukes a moon that is
the right size least approximately and
also that has a very particular orbit in
order for the moon to constantly block
out the Sun it would need to orbit the
planet at the same rate that the planet
orbits the Sun such that it constantly
appears in the sky in the same location
as the Sun even a slight mismatch of
these orbits would result in the
phenomenon being temporary the odds of
this happening are astronomically small
but the universe is a big place
we can't categorically rule out that it
couldn't exist so yeah Sparkle time
might just be possible vanaheim is an
earth clay
a terrestrial planet with temperate
atmosphere and the extras from Game of
Thrones sitting around nothing terribly
interesting here it's so similar to
earth that it could definitely exist
useful home and Niflheim are only very
briefly shown in the sky over London
during the convergence event and there's
really not enough to go on to rule on
feasibility useful home appears in
greater detail in thor ragnarok though
so we'll come back to it there we are
briefly stuck back on earth with Captain
America the Winter Soldier before things
go completely nuts in by god they
actually learned how to make a
nice-looking movie after Peter quill is
picked up from Earth we're introduced to
three new planets Morag Xander and
nowhere which isn't technically a planet
but we'll roll a bit more Ike is the
planet where star-lord
who picks up the orb containing the
Power Stone and seems to be very similar
to earth but with several moons or other
planets looming large in the sky this
may seem like pure fantasy but we've
actually observed planetary systems with
planets so close together that they
would appear this large in the sky
Trappist one for example is a star with
seven planets orbiting so close to one
another that if you were to stand on the
surface of one of them other planets
would appear in the sky overhead even if
only briefly during their orbits we'll
come back to this topic in a little bit
when talking about another movie Morag
however very possible the Xander the
planet they paid Glenn Close to be on is
an earth-like planet in a triple star
system that is with three stars orbiting
each other and in turn orbited by
planets multiple star systems are
surprisingly common with our nearest
stellar neighbour the Alpha Centauri
system containing three stars finding a
planet in a triple star system is less
common but in 2016 just such a system
was discovered in the constellation
Centaurus the planet koechli named HD
one three one three nine nine a B orbits
one star which is in turn orbited by a
pair of stars this unusual configuration
suggests that planets with multiple Suns
may exist across the galaxy so Xand are
very possible that leaves nowhere
no where is the severed head of a
celestial avatar an ancient being rather
than a planet it's so huge that it might
as well be though however while it might
be the size of a planet it does not obey
the laws of planetary science if it were
made of rock it would have collapsed
under the force of gravity and its own a
stirrer st that is how unfair it is
planets like to be spheres or steroidal
accounting for rotation because it's the
way of combining a lot of rock together
with the least possible potential energy
if a planet had a more complicated shape
than rock further from the center of
mass could fall to a location closer to
the center of mass gaining kinetic
energy if everything is equally far away
from the center of mass are you a sphere
then nothing can fall anywhere
it's the minimal energy configuration
nowhere however is very much not a
sphere in that it's a skull but as such
it's made of some unspecified alien
material that we don't know the
properties of and because we can't
assume the physical properties will be
like those of rocks that make up the
planets that we've discovered so far we
can't definitively rule out its
existence
citing how the rocks would fracture and
fall apart into the sphere so it could
exist sure why not skipping over several
films that again only feature earth
taking us from phase 2 to phase 3 we
find ourselves back with the guardians
in
and things are about to get a bit crazy
Guardians 2 features the most planets of
any movie in the MCU a staggering 12
we've already met earth but the rest of
them are completely new the first of
these is sovereign which isn't a single
planet that rather a collection of
planets that resemble Donald Trump's
apartment orbiting so incredibly close
together that they cast shadows on one
another while we saw earlier that more
act similar to the Trappist 1 system
could have planets orbiting close by
close enough to see there's a limit to
how close planetary bodies can orbit one
another without tearing each other apart
specifically this is known as the Roche
limit this is the distance from an
astronomical object that a satellite
such as a moon can orbit without being
torn apart by tidal forces tidal forces
are forces inside a satellite caused by
a strong gradient in the local
gravitational field the side of a
satellite closer to the object it's
orbiting will experience a stronger
gravitational pull than the side further
away because the satellite isn't a
single solid object this will act to
pull the satellite apart far away from
the object it's orbiting this will be a
negligible effect but get close enough
go past the Roche limit of the object
and the satellite will be torn asunder
assuming that the planets comprising
soverign are made of the same material
and so have the same density the Roche
limit is given by this simplified
equation in other words if a planet is
orbiting another larger planet in
sovereign and to distance less than one
and a quarter the radius of the larger
planet it will be inside the Roche limit
that is definitely the case for the
planets shown here and so they are too
close to each other to exist in a stable
configuration so the planet system could
not exist as shown
yeesh after leaving sovereign with the
harbor Larry batteries the guardians are
pursued for an asteroid filled with a
bit of quantum mechanics thrown in the
quantum asteroid field appears similar
to the asteroid belts that we have in
our solar system but the asteroids are
blinking in and out of existence we've
never seen anything like this and for
good reason
quantum mechanics is the fundamental
theory explaining some of the smaller
scale interactions in the universe
between fundamental particles like
electrons and photons at a key component
of the theory is the randomness inherent
in physical systems known as quantum
indeterminacy the quantum asteroid field
exhibits indeterminacy in the position
of each asteroid one moment an asteroid
is here the next it's there there is a
major problem with this however and
that's the size of these asteroids
quantum mechanics applies on small scale
such as when you're describing
individual atoms describing objects
larger than atoms results in quantum
effects being lost as the object
interacts with its environment a process
called quantum decoherence think of it
like this quantum effects are lost over
time as an object interacts with its
environment in much the same way that
energy is lost in a mechanical system
due to friction the larger the quantum
object the faster quantum effects are
lost like in a system with a lot of
friction energy is lost very quickly so
while a quantum object exhibiting
indeterminacy could be as large as an
asteroid it would not stay a quantum
object for more than a fraction of a
second as such the quantum asteroid
field could not exist as shown which is
a shame because it looks bloody awesome
after this the movie features a baffling
array of planets some of which we learn
very little about because they only
feature on screen for a few seconds so
quick fire around
[Music]
bear hurt the planet where the Guardians
crash basically an earth plane with four
moons seems possible to meet contracts
EA the icy planet with a slight cameo a
terrestrial ice planet much like Hoff in
Star Wars actually go check out our
video on planets in star wars 4 wide
that one could exist seasick where ego
starts an aggressive expansion honestly
too little information to go on our ego
7 same problem color which first
features in this film and then more
extensively in Captain Marvel as the
kre-o well an earth-like planet again we
have so little to go on that there's
nothing to suggest it couldn't exist
how about rear ok this is an interesting
one in the clip we see a murky
atmosphere and some of rora
which are orange rather than blue red
and green we see on earth the color of
the aurora on a planet is due to the
chemical composition of its atmosphere
almost entirely oxygen and nitrogen on
earth which gets excited by energetic
particles from the Sun which causes the
aurora orange aurora would be possible
if the atmosphere on rio was comprised
of calcium gas
calcium's one of the most common metals
in the universe though it's not a gas
that we see in large concentrations in
EXO planetary atmospheres it's rock
forming element rarely seen on its own
so unless calcium was being outgassed
somehow through some unknown chemical
process I'd actually go if not possible
on this one ok so what about a con a con
has some funky looking pink vegetation
and it orbits a blue star this is most
likely in O or B type star which is some
of the hottest and fastest live stars in
the universe the whole live hot daeyoung
thing really started in the stars the
question here then is would there be
enough time for complex life to evolve
on that planet considering that the star
doesn't have a long life cycle and the
planet would be bombarded by strong UV
and x-ray radiation from its star way
more than we have here on earth for a
Khan to be habitable as well as
evolution happening quickly the
atmosphere would need to contain strong
UV and x-ray absorbers similar to ozone
in the Earth's atmosphere
this could shift the peak wavelength of
the stellar light to the
so you might result in redder looking
vegetation so I'd say it's plausible but
a particular string of requirements must
be met for this to work
still though possible that then leaves
egos planet which is well if it's a
planet that's also a person who's a god
small geez surface gravity aside this
one is outside of our expertise and
firmly in the realm of fantasy so much
like with nowhere we'll have to concede
that with some celestial materials it
could possibly exist after the madness
of guardians - we briefly returned to
earth in spider-man homecoming before
heading over to possibly the weirdest
planet of all in flash thordan wait I
mean
[Music]
Sekar is a planet made of trash the
planet forming from the excretion of
lots of portals most famously the
devil's anus the materials different but
the gradual accumulation of matter is
exactly how one of the ways the planets
can form planets form from sticking
together rocky material initially dust
and then later rocks and larger
planetesimals this is the material left
over from the formation of star so car
seems to be the end result of the same
process but instead of being accumulated
dust around a star it's the central
point of rubbish shot from wormholes in
otherwise empty space the film seems to
show objects traveling out of the
portals at low ie collisional speeds
which would result in sticking together
rather than shattering on impact over
time the garbage from the portals would
most likely form a planet of some kind
there are a few questions though Sekar
experiences both day and night
which implies that rotates near a star
yet this isn't clearly shown in the film
and isn't implied by the Disneyland ride
thought goes on maybe Sircar is actually
a layer of garbage on top of an existing
small planet around a star
perhaps the Grand Master isn't totally
reliable as a narrator in addition
though a nearby star would subjects a
car to harmful radiation and energetic
particles that we are shielded from on
earth by our planet's magnetic field
that magnetic field is created by our
planets molten iron core it acts like a
giant magnet
if Sekar is made of trash then it's
highly unlikely to have a strong
magnetic field unless the metal pieces
of trash that landed there all sank to
the core of the planet and formed a
molten layer which would potentially
generate a magnetic field perhaps the
portals also have a magnetic moment but
additionally the atmosphere of the
planet would be the result of outgassing
of the material that collected there it
would be a concentrated version of the
air inside rubbish dumps - the oxygen
while it would have an atmosphere it
would be incredibly toxic and quite
possibly extremely flammable was it
snowing
so a trash plant like Sekar could
physically exist but it definitely
wouldn't be habitable and so without
getting into the weird flow of time on
Sekar we're gonna have to say it
couldn't exist as Shane
we're not done with thor ragnarok yet
though we've had Jotunheim we've had
slaughter of home we've had nifflheim
and now we have Muspelheim and anaheim
wait no sorry hell hell is actually only
briefly featured and appears to be like
earth but with a thick atmosphere and
slow motion so it seems very possible
Muspelheim on the other hand actually
looks like hell somewhat confusingly it
actually looks just like Earth during
the Hadean period which we also covered
in our Star Wars video however given
we're dealing with an Asgardian for the
point about habitability in that video
doesn't really apply here the GOG scene
in the movie is also very similar to
volcanic regions on earth with volcanic
columns as seen for example in Fingal's
cave in Scotland
so both hell and moose boeheim could
really exist skipping over earthbound
black panther that brings us up to
Avengers infinity war which is largely
sat on planets away from Earth we've
already covered nowhere but the others
are new to us Vermeer is the planet
where the soul stone is kept and
probably the most visually striking
world in the MCU in the sky of for Mia
we see another Eclipse star with an
extremely active Corona jumping ahead to
Avengers endgame it isn't a spoiler to
say that the star is still eclipsed in
another scene set on the planet that
implies that the star is also
permanently eclipsed like svartalfheim
oh I don't know how to say that name
again this would be possible if for Mia
had a moon with exactly the right
orbital parameters and it's implied in
this one shot that it possibly has two
means one with an atmosphere in fact the
ring of fire surrounding the other moon
may well be a backlit atmosphere by the
same process that turns sunsets on earth
reddy-orange the Starlight would be
shifted to the red by passing through
the atmosphere of the moon there is a
lot to unpack in this screenshot though
from the cosmic horror on the left
cloud reaching the surface of the
planets pole to the beam of energy
coming in from the left the only thing
we've observed that resembles this is a
beam of energetic particles known as an
Astrophysical jet fired out of the poles
of massive rotating objects such as
black holes for the beam to be this
tight
however the planet would need to be in
the immediate vicinity of a supermassive
object otherwise the beam would be much
more spread out being in the immediate
vicinity however would render a delicate
balance of orbits as the moon's would
need to constantly block out the Sun
impossible so vomit could not exist new
devaglia
or never D'Elia as Thor says it sounds
like a made-up word the home of the
dwarf drawing a tree is a stellar forge
this is neither a planet nor a star but
a huge structure entirely surrounding a
neutron star which is in turn surrounded
by several rings it's an example of a
Dyson Sphere a hypothetical structure
that encompasses a star and captures its
power output in this case to power a
forge we don't want to dwell on this
design of the forge too much or how it
would operate instead we're talking
about the feasibility of the physical
structure here
and much like nowhere we don't know what
sci-fi materials this structure would be
made of or how responsive it could be to
small-scale changes in gravitational
field of the star that unchecked could
tear the sphere apart or for that matter
how it would deal with external for
things like being hit by debris or
asteroids so assuming those problems are
dealt with this is a tentative
hypothetical may be possible given some
incredible sci-fi technology spherical
symmetry is really lending a hand here
but definitely beyond us humans for the
foreseeable future
people are so petty and tiny
that leaves Titan the homeworld of
Thanos where a lot of the action in
infinity war takes place someone
confusingly this is not the same Titan
that we have in our solar system the
moon of Saturn which is on its own super
interesting so we shouldn't compare the
as shown to that moon what we do know
about the planet is what star-lord says
upon arrival it's eight degrees off its
axis gravitational pull is all over the
place
Starwood says this as if it's incredibly
unusual but earth is 23 degrees off-axis
in our orbit this tilt is what causes
the seasons it's not clear how a planet
being eight degrees off-axis would have
the dramatic effects that we see on
titan compared to what Faneuil shows us
it was like before in fact eight degrees
is fairly small when we look at our
solar system planets where the earth is
tilted to 23 degrees and Venus is
basically spinning backwards and upside
down we have a tilt of a hundred and
seventy-seven degrees what this could
mean instead is that the planets
experience a rapid axial precession
angle of 8 degrees essentially going
from tilting in one direction by eight
degrees then the other by eight degrees
in a circle like when a spinning top is
not perfectly straight and it tilts one
way than the other in one rotation
drawing out a circle on the tabletop if
the planets doing this quickly enough it
would cause some dramatic effects on the
internal dynamics of its liquid core or
mantle which in turn could cause twists
in the magnetic field and changes in the
gravitational field that would be
chaotic I'm gonna say this straight up
though without a supercomputer we really
don't know what effects this would cause
it's a really complicated problem to
solve the earth actually also has an
axial precession but it's on the order
of twenty five thousand years which is
very long and will not cause any harm to
earth or us it just changes the seasons
a little bit over a long time so if we
ramp up axial precession to 11 caused by
some unknown event on the planet may be
irresponsible geothermal energy
harvesting Titan could exist but I am
speculating wildly that's not it for
infinity war though as the very last
scene of the film is Thanos on Titan -
otherwise known as the garden this is a
pretty standard earth-like world with
some large moons and as seen at the
start of the endgame a ring of matter
around it similar to Saturn while we
associate rings with the large planets
in our solar system it is possible for
terrestrial planets to have them to the
dwarf planet how may
orbiting outside of Neptune's orbit has
both moons and a ring of material so
with this precedent and otherwise being
like earth the garden is very possible
man after you examine a planet literally
made out of garbage everything else
seems so banal are you yawning skipping
over Ant Man and the wasp we come to a
final new planet in Captain Marvel as we
previously said when talking about
guardians to Captain Marvel features
Halle the homeworld of the cream as well
as earth and new planet Topher Topher is
an earth-like planet with a thick dusty
atmosphere and blue soil a thick
atmosphere on a terrestrial planet is
very possible and the orange color of it
would make sense if the atmosphere was
denser than the Earth's perhaps as a
result of more extensive outgassing from
more active plate tectonics or volcanoes
for example the blue soil is an
interesting one it could be the result
of microbial life such as cyanobacteria
or it's simply a result of being rich in
copper copper turns blue when oxidized
and when bonded with ammonia it creates
a deep blue compound called a mean so
our final planet topher could exist that
means then that of the 28 planetary
bodies considered in this video 3 we
just have too little information to go
on 6 Asgard sovereign the quantum
asteroid field Rhea
Sekar and Vermeer couldn't exist and the
rest are possible to varying degrees
looking at use fossil time while pretty
wild the planets of the MCU still only
scratch the surface of what is possible
in our last video together Hannah you
talked about hot Jupiters and how you'd
like to see more of them in science
fiction what are other possible planets
that we still haven't seen in sci-fi
there are so many different planets that
are left to explore planets with their
atmosphere being stripped off by their
stars water worlds without mercy is of
steam or planets with solid ice crusts
and deepwater sub oceans what would life
be like on the moon like Enceladus for
example in our solar system which is
liquid ocean between 60 kilometre ice
sheets what about a giant ring system
with blocks out the star periodically
causing varying
day/night Eclipse cycles on the planet
what would that do to life then a
tidally locked planet with a permanent
day side in a permanent night side
something which is very common in our
most studied exoplanets oh clouds made
of rubies and sapphires okay I'm gonna
stop
don't worry Hannah in this video we drew
on concepts from quantum mechanics
orbital mechanics electromagnetism and
atmospheric physics if you've always
wanted to learn more about these topics
then the best way is to solve practice
problems but where to start
how do you find good problems with clear
explanations of the subject matter
the answer is educational website
brilliant org brilliant has dozens of
courses written by experts across maths
and science which are enjoyed by over
seven million users you can study all of
the topics we introduced in this video
and beyond in particular if you enjoyed
the discussion of quantum mechanics then
you should check out their excellent
course on quantum computing I wish that
I'd had access to brilliant when I was
at school the website makes an excellent
companion to study at senior levels as
well as a standalone educational service
for curious adults their offline courses
in their apps for iOS and Android make
learning a little bit each day through
practice problems on your commute or in
your lunch break as easy as pie
sorry - get smarter at maths and science
go to brilliant dog forward slash Simon
Clark and the first 200 people to use
promo codes Simon Clark will get to 20%
off their premium annual subscription
thank you for watching this video it has
been a real labor of love over several
months and huge thanks must go - Hannah
- dr. waetford for her endless
enthusiasm and expertise and frankly
patience with me so thank you Hannah
also thank you to dr. Thomas Preston who
gave a consultation on the quantum
asteroid field if you found this video
interesting then definitely check out
our previous video on the planets in the
Star Wars films and if you'd like to see
behind the curtain or if you just like
to support my work then you can do so on
my patreon there is an extensive
behind-the-scenes video outlining how I
made this how we research this video
thank you so much for watching to the
end and I'll see you in the next one